all right James thank you so much for
being here today thank you for having me
of course so to start I want to ask you
what experience or Insight prompted you
to start your company yeah
um
just a I guess a 20-second background to
get to that is I grew up in the DRC in
Kinshasa my family's been there for
three generations so that's my whole
life ended up in New York studying
computer science at NYU 2015 sophomore
year was my first time actually
interacting with crypto about my first
ethereum we're studying compsi class and
I was sending money back home uh to a
friend and as I discovered it I feel
like growing up in Africa Emerging
Market in general if you discover
something like this it's not like oh
this is a stock or this is something
let's make some money off of it this is
like something crazy that you could
never do before because before this it
would be buying gift cards or buying
various other things to get money to
Africa that makes sense and so now tell
me about your journey you're taking it
from an idea to be you know expand
across the content and then expand
globally what's that been like and what
are the challenges like sure I think I
got into crypto just in general just
three reasons Banking and Bank
cross-border payments and remittances
and these are three problems that you
really see in Africa if you live here so
for us it's been quite a journey 2021
November is uh I started jumbo we
essentially had some a few friends
support us very lucky a few investors
and we did a c round then off some good
numbers we did a series day I think at
the end of the day though expanding in
Africa people say like it's one region
or one country but honestly you're
talking about billions of people 57
countries only one Botswana that has
given the first crypto license in all of
Africa wow yes so dealing with each sort
of regions
um different things is very hard I'd say
I had to localize yes and you mentioned
that you raised that series a what's
your experience in like raising capital
in Africa great question
um
I think just from talking to investors
it's weird because usually we talk to
investors they know everything you know
about your topic before you even talk to
them that's the only reason the investor
but for Africa 95 plus of our investors
have never been here or never even
invested into the region so for me it
really was a process of explaining what
Africa is the growth smartphone
penetration 50 three of the top 10
countries uh crypto peer-to-peer
transaction volume the youngest
population once they start to see I
guess these Trends they're more
interested and then we can go into the
nitty-gritty details and that's whether
jumbo or myself is the right team to do
this but I think end of the day more and
more investors are getting recognition
for Africa and investing again because
of guys that have gone out to really
approach the law such as even yellow
card Chris now on the panel they
probably did one of the best races
giving exposure to Africa as well
turned to a little bit of a harder
question here you know in the U.S we are
really negative on crypto right now
especially for everything with FDX yes
how are you looking at that situation
and what are you telling people about
you know you and your business and the
stability of it yes
um
I think dealing with Africa and every
country in Africa is like very surprised
me just seeing how a lot of the things
turned out this year in the US for
regulation Etc because we obviously know
I think it was Ryan selkis and I'm sorry
that I wrote this on Twitter the other
day but if America does not become a not
even say crypto Haven by at least sort
of a middle ground for it crypto as an
industry we all will suffer for a lot
more time for adoption so I think
America is like super key for just
crypto adoption in the future but on the
opposite end of spectrum we see emerging
markets and a lot of the sort of great
policies that come out to attract new
people so um I think this next 10 years
will be very interesting
going along with that what's the biggest
hurdle you have faced either you know
getting people to adopt crypto or to
give your company a chance and how have
you overcome that
um I would say language barriers might
be one of the biggest things because
we're in 14 regions at the moment and
obviously a lot of them are francophone
speaking so myself my sister Kofi we
grew up in Congo so we do speak French
that was mother tongue but for if when
you're hiring and Etc you have to do a
lot of things yourself you have to be in
the region and our team right now is a
bit over a hundred uh mostly full-time
so I'm part-time so all of those took a
long time to uh I guess build up what
would you say are the biggest
misconceptions about being an
entrepreneur in Africa
um I guess that you have to look African
I'm joking no the reason the reason
being um it was funny because during our
Zoom raise right so I raised during a
weird time I was during covid so
everything was on zoom and most
investors when they were intro hey you
guys want to talk to this project from
DRC building the super app for Africa
they're expecting someone not looking
like me to pop on the zoom screen uh so
I guess that's one but
I say mostly a lot is around the
financial system where
say even let's take away from even
running like an entrepreneurial crazy
business let's just say you you make
furniture you sell wood and you need to
buy wood from various places even to
play your supplier or to receive money
you can't do that right now because
there's no cross-board payments so you
need companies like yellow car like ovex
guys that do crossword payments and
exchanges and OTC to help facilitate
that so honestly I really don't see a
lot of things that are going on in
Africa the challenges as something that
people are trying to solve just for
solving it to make their company better
it's more like it's a problem that
everyone sees it's like you know it's uh
when you you're traveling and you didn't
unpack your luggage you see it there
every day but no one's doing anything
about it so um just trying to I guess
enable these infrastructures so I'm
going to ask you a fun one now and I ask
a lot of young Founders this what would
it take to get you to sell your company
um that's a great that's a really great
question actually it says a lot about
the company yeah honestly every investor
should ask that question surprising not
have
um
I'd say we would have to have
accomplished something close to what we
really set out to accomplish now the
reason I say this is because you know as
you know my family's been in Africa for
Congo three generations my sister is my
co-founder essentially we're putting
everything all of our family reputation
everything on the line to do these
concurrent joint ventures in these 14
regions to to build using all of our
working with all of our partners and Etc
um so honestly this is like we never set
out for this to be in a time but Market
start going things at least a five to
ten year like goal to build a web 3 in
Africa uh if you ask me about exit I
would have to say that whoever buys the
company or hopefully something
Etc is someone that actually builds a
lot in Africa and we can work together
and one final
question we've talked about
um well hopefully when I come to
Botswana in 10 years I can download the
Jamba application and use it to do all
kinds of on-rail and off-railing but as
well as make money that's that would
honestly be the craziest thing yes
amazing well thank you so much thank you